are you human
did my body give it away I try hard save
mystery yeah I'm human are you
I've wanted to make a Halloween video
about Soma for four years now ever since
I first played the game and that's
because it has one of the best video
game stories of all time despite being
an almost walking simulator Soma is a
horror game that is able to capture a
glimpse of what storytelling can be at
its best in video games it tells a story
and delivers an experience that can only
happen in a video game and at the same
time it leaves us questioning our sense
of self what it means to be human and
what makes life valuable in this video I
want to talk about how Soma succeeds and
that's going to require I spoil the main
plot points of the game I highly highly
recommend that you play Soma before
watching this video and with that let's
see why more video games should be like
Soma
The Core theme of Soma is body namely
the protagonist's body the word Soma is
literally the Greek word for body and
The Game's plot focuses on the
relationship between mind and body and
the protagonist Simon Jarrett and in
others throughout the game
to set the stage a bit you play as Simon
a man with head trauma who goes to see a
shady doctor for a headscan after the
scan you wake up in some underwater
facility and have to figure out what's
going on you come across monsters robots
that seem to be infused with human minds
and eventually one friendly voice Dr
Catherine chunt who becomes your
companion for most of the game now this
is your last chance to avoid Major
Spoilers as you progress through the
game you realize a lot of time has
passed since that initial brain scan
civilization has apparently collapsed
due to a meteor impact with only this
underwater facility pathos 2 remaining
as you work your way through its
stations you come across robots which
seem to think they are human some even
get angry when you try to tell them what
they really are
[Music]
then you come across Catherine and you
find her in a similar State though she
is aware of her cyborg properties and
seems okay with it even more she points
out that Simon is in the same boat have
you looked at yourself lately you're a
walking talking diving suit with some
Electronics left on for good measure I
don't you don't want to think about it
we'll start thinking about it Catherine
explains what's going on as a final
measure against the end of the world
Humanity would be preserved digitally
through her project here at pathos 2. I
say saved all the people on the station
as brain scans and put them into an
artificial world
we were going to launch it into space to
save it from uh well all of this you
find out that the brain scan from the
beginning of the game copied your
Consciousness which was then uploaded
into your diving suit body to start the
game the original Flesh and Blood Simon
died decades ago but importantly this
process was a copy and paste not a cut
and paste the original Simon continued
living his life after the scan he never
had any experience in pathos 2. the game
has us undergo this copy and paste two
more times and each time it is a pivotal
moment in the story The two additional
transfers that happen at pathos 2 both
involve putting Simon's Consciousness in
a new body the first time is because he
needs a stronger suit to go deeper
underwater and the second time is the
final uploading of his Consciousness
onto the artificial World Catherine made
called The Arc as it heads to space the
second moment is basically the end of
the game and is probably what most
players will chiefly remember it has a
lot of emotional weight but I would
argue that the first transfer is at
least as if not more important in the
latter half of the game Simon needs to
go deeper into the water to complete his
mission of sending the ark to space and
this requires a stronger suit to
withstand the increased pressure so you
follow Catherine's guidance and prepare
the transfer she copies your
Consciousness and puts it into the new
suit but then something goes wrong you
as Simon wake up in the new body but the
old Simon can be heard muttering just a
few words before Catherine forcefully
sedates him
foreign
this breaks something in the mind of
Simon the one in the second suit
two Simons there can't be two Simons
even though he had it laid out before
Simon never realized or let himself own
up to the fact that the process was copy
and paste not cut and paste not anything
like a brain transplant as he says he
always thought there was just the one
him continuing through life when he
realizes that's not true that there are
multiple Simons he loses it he lashes
out a Catherine saying how did you
expect me to react to this [ __ ] please
stop you're [ __ ] disgusting
Simon thought he was always himself just
shifting from one body to another in
reality it would probably be fairer to
say that he was being cloned each copy
and paste creating another Simon to
experience reality for the most part the
game only follows the conscious
experience of one of these Simons except
for this small moment were two overlap
however briefly the game has this whole
experience of going through the scans
not realizing what was going on
retroactively being shown that you are
not who you thought you were all of that
Simon and the player go through together
as one unit and here the player and
Simon are confronted together there are
two Simons but only one of them is us
the player and only one feels real to
the second suit Simon this kind of story
and critical moment in a movie or book
or any other medium wouldn't work the
same in any other medium the person
experiencing the work wouldn't be able
to go back and stare at the player model
the body that they inhabited up to the
point but that's exactly what we get to
do with Simon yes maybe Simon reacts
more harshly than the player might feel
but overall I found the coalescence of
the player and Simon in this moment to
be an almost perfect mesh between game
and player Simon's confusion over who he
is and what has happened occurs in line
with our confusion over taking up this
new body and realizing that from the
first brain scan our sense of self was
wrong plus there's the decision of what
to do with the old diving suit Simon too
to let him wake up and live alone in
this section of the station or to pull
the plug drain his battery and leave
only one Simon still alive the sequence
and the whole game really use these
themes of body and mind really well to
make us question our personal identity
an important philosophical topic who is
the real Simon throughout the game does
a twice copied clone get to think of
themselves as being identical with the
original human and what makes Simon
Simon after each copy and paste these
questions are what Simon and we as the
player have to Grapple with to me in
contrast with the name of the game the
body is the less important part as each
Simon has the same Consciousness at
least at the point of the copying they
are all still Simon though once their
life experiences diverge they each begin
to take on their own new identity
the beautiful thing is that this
exploration of personal identity gets to
be so visceral and real because Soma is
a video game and not any other kind of
media we play in first person as Simon
we get to feel and act as him in a way
more real than with films or books great
works in these other media May evoke
sympathy or feelings of likeness in good
cases they let us relate to the
characters but they do not let the
person experiencing them be the depicted
subject like a game does there is a
game's philosopher see the Nguyen who I
cited in my Eldon ring philosophy video
and he captures this unique aspect of
games masterfully in his book games
agency as art in the work nguin charts
how games occupy a distinct artistic
space because they use the medium of
agency games let us take on a temporary
agency a way of being or an attitude or
headspace with specific desires or goals
as new in writes games turn out to be a
way of writing down forms of agency of
inscribing them in in an artifact games
are one of our techniques where
inscribing and recording Bits Of Human
Experience instead of recording a
beautiful sound a stunning image or an
evocative turn of phrase games record
Human Experience a way of being or
feeling or thinking and doing for
example a game like twister records and
presents a fun goofy agency when you
play it you generally take on a
light-hearted attitude on the other hand
a game like chess gives a focused
tactical mindset generally a much more
serious attitude and circling back a
game like Soma delivers the agency of
Simon Jarrett actually a few Simon
jarretts as they grapple with the
horrors of pathos 2 and what it means to
be a person what it means to be
themselves I could also talk about the
final copy and paste in the game the
decisive moments where big spoiler alert
here Bjork is launched into space but we
as players remain with the second suit
Simon and pathos 2. here we get to see
the other side of the agency coin flip
where we are the ones left behind
this fleshes out the copy paste idea and
it serves as a strong emotional note
that stays with the player of second
suit Simon's desperation but still I
think everything we really need to look
at is in that first moment the second is
a great addition to the game but the
first can stand on its own to show us
what kind of medium video games are and
can be game designers and games in the
future would do well to incorporate this
kind of use of the medium these are
games not books or movies or anything
else and they can Shine for that reason
and they are video games too so of
course keep throwing in all the
beautiful landscapes and soundscapes for
sure I just think that focusing on the
medium specific stuff the role of agency
the engagement of gameplay is what will
really deliver the best gaming
experiences and the real moments of
beauty now Soma obviously could make
better use of the fact that it's a game
in the gameplay category as I said it's
almost a walking simulator and it could
really benefit from some more developed
gameplay mechanics but nonetheless it
still stands as one of the best gaming
experiences I've ever had the two
climaxes of the game were to me glimpses
into what the medium can achieve and I'm
excited to see more of that in future
games if you liked the video feel free
to subscribe to the channel or support
me on patreon as I'll be doing more game
analysis like this in the future
recently I've done mainly Elden ring
stuff but I want to make it known that
I'm not literally just an elder ringa
even though I know making that
distinction will have a slow start I'm
sure this video won't do too well in the
algorithm metrics but I think it's still
important to pursue what is Meaningful
even if it's not as commercially
successful though to any Elden ring
Watchers that have made it this far be
on the lookout for more lore soon as
it's coming thanks for watching thanks
to my patrons for supporting the channel
and with that peace and just one final
note in the form of a PS after the video
the game does show the other Simon on
the arc so it technically doesn't only
follow one Simon's Consciousness
throughout the game but that's such a
minor point to the overall Narrative of
the game following the one Consciousness
that I think it's okay to not bring that
up to centrally in this analysis thanks
for watching peace for real this time
bye